ده رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الجمهوريه
الاوكرانيه اندري يير ماكلين شيء محكمه
دوليه خاصه بجريمه العدوان التي ارتكبتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا بحسب وصفه وخلال خطاب
عبر الانترنت في منتدى دافوس حتى يرمك
شركاء بلاده على تطوير اليات تتيح مصادره
الاصول الروسيه لتعويض الخسائر التي
سببتها الحرب
الروسيه
على جرائمها فهناك حاجه مرحه الى انشاء
محكمه خاصه يمكنها العمل بشكل اسرع واكثر
كفاءه بما ان المحكمه الغنائيه الدوليه
ليست بها الولايات القضائيه
وشركائها يفعلون كل ما في وسطهم لانشاء
هذه المحكمه الخاصه
يونايتد الى ذلك قال المفوض الاوروبي
المكلف بملف العدل لدي رينز علينا الاتحاد
سيخصصه الدعم الماليا للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه للتحقيق في جرائم الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا على حد قوله
من العقاب وفي العام الجاري سندعم محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه بسبعه ملايين يورو
للفتره الممتده بين 2021 و 2027
اضافه الى تقديم دعم الاستثنائيا اوروبي
لمكتب المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كريم خان وتمت المصادقه على الدعم
الذي سيخصصه لمتابعه جرائم الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا في يونيو الماضي